[Risas]
[Música]
dónde está la sabiduría que perdimos en
el conocimiento donde está el
conocimiento que perdimos de la
información existen investigaciones de
la neurociencia que han demostrado que
la relación de las niñas y niños es
decir de las guaguas con las de los
adultos causó un gran impacto en el
desarrollo del cerebro desde la etapa
prenatal en que por ejemplo afirma que
las experiencias de esta relación
directa o adulta son vitales para la
integración sensorial para los procesos
de atención de autorregulación el
desarrollo del pensamiento crítico es
decir que se refleja en la calidad de
las habilidades tanto intelectuales
físicas emocionales sociales y morales
que tiene cada persona entonces cómo
explicar la real y aterradora crisis
climática y crisis civilizatoria en la
que nos encontramos
de tanto conocimiento e información que
tenemos o deberíamos tener hasta el día
de hoy siete años en la escuela y nueve
quienes estuvieron desde el inicial uno
otros seis años en el colegio cuatro
años de la universidad quienes
estudiamos aproximadamente como unos
diecisiete años desperdiciados o
incompletos o injustos o vacíos porque
no cabe duda de lo que dice rengifo el
proyecto educativo occidental no es nada
ajeno a lo que le está ocurriendo a la
naturaleza al mundo feminicidios
genocidios ecocidios sequías extremas de
escasez de agua nuevas temperaturas
extremas de la tierra en el mar en el
ártico los científicos predicen la casi
total desaparición de las selvas para el
año 2030 y etcétera etcétera datos más y
más alarmantes entonces recuperar la
sabiduría que perdimos en el
conocimiento de información viene a ser
urgente y para esto es necesario
recuperar la memoria del corazón cuya
escuela más grande y viva
afortunadamente aún existe en los
pueblos originarios
campesinos y para que no digan que es
una cosa de indígenas o de esa gente que
está pegada a la tierra les comentó que
desde la neuro cardiología nos explican
que el cerebro tiene su corazón perdón
tiene su propio pequeño cerebro de unas
50 mil neuronas que le otorgan la
capacidad de sentir y pensar de forma
independiente y de procesar información
y tomar decisiones desde el corazón
yo tuve una infancia diferente como
todas obviamente tuve una educación una
crianza diferente recuerdo que desde
guagua me decían que la pah chema mitad
del aespa mamá laia cv mama sentían que
escuchaban que conversaban que había que
darle sus palitos sus ritual hitos que
nosotros éramos sus hijas que somos sus
hijas y que nuestro color de piel los
reflejaba me hacían sentir afortunada
privilegio que todas las personas
realizadas no la tenemos a lo largo de
nuestras vidas injustamente pero
recuerdo que mi mamá mi profesora le
hablaban en las semillitas le hablaban
en las plantas yo mi corazón mi cerebro
guardábamos memoria de todo y mi hermano
sin si hecho también hace algunos años
en un encuentro de derechos de la niñez
y adolescencia en la ciudad de quito nos
hicieron algunos ejercicios bastante
interesantes uno de esos era hacer y
contar una historia de nuestras mascotas
de con quiénes jugábamos con quiénes nos
divertíamos a quienes les contábamos
nuestras preocupaciones alegrías
tristezas de con quienes nos sentíamos
acompañadas con quienes compartíamos
tiempo
y la mayoría a todas y todas las
historias bien bien bonitas de sus
perros y de sus gatos mientras que mi
hermano hizo de su planta de fresa y era
increíble para mí yo me sentía
completamente representada porque para
mí también lo era y sí todas y todos se
rieron y para algunas también fue les
causó ternura nosotros éramos los únicos
indígenas en ese grupo y después de que
yo escuché que se rieron yo no quise
contar nada más y prefieren sumarme a la
historia de de alguien más yo tenía unos
8 años y guardo esta memoria y guardo
este recuerdo como escuela de
cuestionamiento de insurgencia de
coherencia y de posibilidad porque
afortunadamente la escuela en la que
nosotros estuvimos permitió que así
fuera
al día siguiente nosotros regresamos de
la escuela y les contamos y nunca se
burlaron nunca lo minimizaron nunca lo
invisibilizaron lo tomaron como
importante porque era importante y a
partir de ello fuimos más bien
desarrollando y creando este sentimiento
ligado al logos en torno a nuestra
concepción de vida durante toda la
escuela
y después crecí y me hice profesora
también y ahí estaba ulises un niño
indígena campesino ulises agrama
indígena campesino de la comunidad de
guamote de chimborazo que recién llegaba
a la ciudad de quito en nuestra escuela
y un día de esos se olvidó sus deberes y
le preguntamos qué pasó y nos respondió
más si disculpa es que el deber no quiso
venir siguiendo no quiso venir siguiendo
acaso ulises era un niño tonto como
debíamos reaccionar nosotras porque no
era nada lógico lo que decía cómo
debíamos reaccionar lógicamente nosotras
o como debíamos nosotras plantearnos de
él quizás de no ser cuestionarles o peor
aún
corregirle o en realidad all is ese era
el problema fiscal h en lengua quichua
significa dos de educaciones dos
conocimientos y es una propuesta
pedagógica pero no de ahora y no de
nosotras de nosotros los ley dos como
decía mi abuelito de cotopaxi es una
demanda de comuneros y comuneras andinas
campesinas de julio de 1990 que busca
contraponer el conocimiento de occidente
moderno y la vivencia y vigencia de los
saberes ancestrales indígenas campesinos
y que ya contempla en el artículo 92 de
la ley orgánica de educación
intercultural del ecuador sin embargo no
se aplica y no se ha sabido cómo aplicar
pero este artículo
busca y muestra la posibilidad y la
urgencia de reconstruir un ecuador sin
la jactancia del paradigma de occidente
moderno y dejar de enmudecer los valores
tradicionales de comverse y de crianza
con la naturaleza y con las comunidades
humanas pero esto no quiere decir que se
cuestiona la presencia de la escuela
moderna no no no en lo absoluto por el
contrario se propicia que se enseñe lo
propio y lo ajeno es decir una escuela
plural y no solamente entregada a la
modernidad
esta propuesta iscayachi plantea que
quienes faciliten la educación sean
mediadores culturales en todas las áreas
es decir que sepan muy bien lo propio y
lo ajeno y siguen se halla bastante
fácil verdad pero seguimos por décadas
con el mismo sistema y paradigma
educativo y las crisis continúan y las
crisis empeora porque no no sabemos lo
propio no nos enseñaron lo propio y por
consecuencia lo ajeno lo sabemos a
medias
y este es el llamado este es el reto
porque se puede aplicar en todo en
matemáticas en idiomas en historia en
ciencia en tecnología en educación
física para aprender a aprender con la
simplicidad de nuestros paisajes locales
vamos a poner algunos ejemplos para
entender mejor por ejemplo en
matemáticas hay varios libros y
contenidos que nos han enseñado a todas
en el colegio por igual verdad
y es importante saberlo claro pero
también existen libros propios
matemática propia también tenemos el
matemático ecuatoriano marcos guerrero
ureña quien le dedicó su vida a la
investigación en esta área y lanzó
algunos libros por ejemplo los dos
máximos sistemas del mundo y la
geometría analítica fractal y la
geometría prehispánica fractal donde
podemos encontrar geometrías de exóticas
como lo que nos han mostrado como
arqueología turística nada más y ahí
está ingapirca engañar ecuador
machu picchu en perú la chakana la cruz
escalonado incaica como eje de
coordinación para medir el volumen de
las montañas
es decir enseñar la matemática desde los
dos conocimientos reconociendo las ambas
existentes importantes necesarias y
aplicables lo mismo podemos hacer en
ciencias naturales con el agua por
ejemplo mientras que para occidente
moderno es una sustancia cuya molécula
está compuesta por dos átomos de
hidrógeno y uno de oxígeno h2o y es
importante este conocimiento por otro
lado para las culturas originarias de
los andes' tiene atributos de persona es
un ser vivo con cultura propia con
lenguaje propio por eso se la defiende
con la vida y si necesitan también que
haya comprobación científica y demás
también existen investigaciones al
respecto como las de mayor en moto por
ejemplo pero vamos con algo más
cotidiano la comida creen ustedes que
que han tenido total poder y libertad de
decisión en lo que compran y en lo que
comen quiénes y dónde nos enseñaron a
comer esto sí y esto no lo propio no hay
lo ajeno así y encima mal porque hay
muchos de alimentos muy nutritivos y
necesarios que no se suelen consumir
quiero decir con esto cuántas de ustedes
conocen y consumen la mayor a la oca la
jícama la la kiwicha el negro y
el maíz rojo rosado gris negro el camote
la papa etcétera etcétera si no conocen
o no han comido significa que
solo conocen una industria alimentaria y
la conocen más y además le dan dinero y
la respalda
a esto esto quiere decir que nos falta
un abanico más de poder entender otras
alternativas otras posibilidades
inclusive en la comida porque es
necesario diversificar nuestros platos
tener los dos conocimientos alimenticios
también en nuestras comidas y también
hay alternativas para hacer
preparaciones y riquísimas porque no se
trata de dejarlo uno por lo otro sino de
contrastarlo es un proceso que hay que
iniciarlo de reaprender a diversificar
nuestras nuestras comidas y de paso la
economía local la salud y el medio
ambiente y bueno podríamos pensar nos de
niscayah chain en absolutamente todas
las áreas académicas y no académicas
siendo indígenas y no indígenas viviendo
en la ciudad y viviendo en el campo
siendo profesionales podríamos también
aprender a trabajar la tierra y crear la
tierra y esto se puede se puede aplicar
absolutamente en toda la vida cotidiana
como les les comentaba
no sé inclusive como les comentaba a la
comida la ropa cómo conseguimos el amor
cómo concebimos y vemos del mundo cómo
conseguimos la escuela la educación la
crianza
y es que esto proponen dos estilos de
vida en congruencia entre sí sin que un
ápice la otra y sobre todo la que
concebimos como universal y moderna pero
sí que entre ambas permitan la
regeneración de nuestra casa común y de
la nuestra como especie porque la
educación no se da solamente en un aula
en una institución se da en
absolutamente todo verdad y no se da
sólo para quienes estudiamos esta
carrera si eres abuela abuelo tía tío
prima primo hermano hermana de sin amigo
y te habrán atravesado o habrás vivido
alguna vez o convivido lo sigues
haciendo con algún bagua y estás
teniendo un rol importante en su
formación en su crianza colectiva o en
el obstáculo de la misma
y entonces ulises a grama lo recuerdan
no era un niño tonto en lo absoluto
tantas y tantos hubiéramos sido nosotras
y nosotros si no teníamos esa capacidad
de entender su cosmovisión porque al
migrar y al viajar viajaba con sus
saberes y su crianza nosotros en el aula
aquella vez lo asumimos
así le agradecemos mucho por el
aprendizaje que nos estaba dando nos
estaba recordando las de los estudiantes
empezaron a hacer preguntas también de
lo que él sabía de cómo era su comunidad
él también les hacía preguntas y se
generó un ambiente muy bonito de
aprendizaje colectivo aprovechamos
también de paso para reforzar en
ciencias ancestrales probióticos y lo
bióticos desde ambos conocimientos y es
que desde diversos ámbitos se mira la
necesidad urgente de que la de los
docentes y de todas y todos quienes
estamos ejerciendo educación en
cualquier contexto
adoptemos enfoques de la educación con
pertinencia cultural con justicia
lingüística justicia social y ecológica
que nuestra educación desarrolle permite
el corazón ar y el pensamiento crítico y
consecuente porque otras escuelas son
posibles otra educación es posible
tienen que levantarse y volver a soñar
sé
me llamo a chi minh aritz in bastante y
ya tengo 25 años y soy de la
nacionalidad kichwa de los pueblos
panzaleo y otavalo
soy magíster en educación para la
justicia social y soy docente de
primaria del sistema de educación
intercultural bilingüe de la escuela ya
chihuas y para terminar quiero
compartirles algo que que mayita mi
abuelita rosamaría simba lema del pueblo
panzaleo de salache no nos decía en sus
palabras que sería mejor campesina la
ciudad o si es ciudadanizar el campo que
tiene que hacer la escuela qué hacemos
nosotras como escuela qué haces tú como
escuela
[Aplausos]